the secret behind a great eggs benedict
is in the hollandaise so get your pan on
because i'm going to cook our
hollandaise over a rolling boil with a
glass bowl
butter just put it on to melt
three egg yolks
separated from the white tarragon
vinegar pop that into the eggs if you
can't get tarragon vinegar any white
wine vinegar will do just as long as
you've got that acidity in there give
some bite to the hollandaise put your
bowl
over the rolling water
and just start whisking
if the eggs had diet contact with the
gas
hollandaise will become scrambled egg
once you've got that nice creamy texture
a nice thick savvy on start adding your
butter
nice and slowly
a couple of tablespoons of butter in
and give that a really nice mix
if you don't whisk it enough the egg
yolks don't take the butter it causes it
to split
with more butter
using a big balloon whisk like this one
makes it easier to incorporate air and
helps prevent your mixture from
separating
all the butter in
and the best way to keep hollandaise
nice and warm is just leave it to sit
over that nice warm water bath and it
just keeps at a really nice room
temperature
a nice pinch of salt
fresh pepper and then fresh lemon juice
that just really makes it vibrant
exciting
i want it's like a sort of thick custard
i just want it to coat the back of the
spoon so it's like you're giving the a
nice glossy texture to your beautiful
poached egg now
as the base for the egg benedict you
cannot beat english muffins but the ham
i'm gonna change i'm gonna use the most
amazing parma ham get your pan nice and
hot
into the pan
it's like posh rashes are bacon
beautiful
[Music]
parlor ham fried nice and crisp like
that is incredible beautiful in salads
fantastic for eggs benedict
[Music]
now keep that pan nice and hot
i want all that flavor from the parmesan
left in there
and rather than toast my muffins i want
to put the muffins into the pan i want
them sucking up all that wonderful
flavor from that crispy parmesan
make sure your muffins are toasted
nicely this will prevent them going
soggy later
look at that
nice and crisp
now water on to boil for the eggs nicely
seasoned really important i mean just a
little splash of vinegar in the water
that helps to set the egg white the
minute you crack it in
while the water heats up in the pan
there's time to get organized
lay a nice slice of ham on the base
now water's brought up to the ball turn
it down and then spin your water around
like a little whirlpool
then get a little cup so you just drop
the cup in
and look what happens to the egg
gets caught up in the turbulence of the
water
the secret is not to ball the water
rapidly because the strength of the ball
can literally explode your egg as they
start to move the way up to the top of
the water that's a indication that
they're cooked
take off any excess little bits of egg
white
and then out onto a piece of tissue
paper
that just drains off excess water that
stops your muffin from getting really
soggy
but look they're like little beautiful
mozzarella balls give them a little
season
lift them on to your crispy parmesan
useful
now get a nice spoon of your hollandaise
glaze over
try and do it in one glazing over the
whole egg
[Applause]
when i tell jack holly and megan and
matilda that we're cooking eggs benedict
for breakfast they bolt down the stairs
and let's be honest who wouldn't run
to sit in front of those
[Music]
a special occasion breakfast that would
make anyone feel spoiled
eggs benedict with crispy parmesan
[Music]
aren't they small yeah it's tiny so it's
almost like a sort of nice
entrance into eating something slightly
gamey
okay if you give them a nice season for
me salt and pepper
and all spatchcock means is that the rib
cage has been taken out and they're
flattened down and because the bird is
so delicate
it's flattened to cook evenly
and
it really is a nice sort of light gamey
dense chicken flavor
so we're toaster spices when you think
of middle eastern food it's packed with
amazing flavors tablespoon of coriander
a teaspoon
of cumin
and a nice little seasoning
of salt so we toast them now
intensifying the flavor
when they start smoking lightly
that's a nice indication that they're
ready
okay
if you grind away so the best thing
there let's just stand a little closer
today thank you
oh look your tummy's out
i thought it was the quail it was a
little tummy this hand here
keeps it nice and firm and you grind
that into a nice powder for belly please
smells so good doesn't it yeah
so to get that in
really go around the outside and that
grinds it up
i've gone around i press the mortar
more times than you kissed boys
squeeze the garlic in next
a little glove
a volleyball
okay then i want you to pour six
tablespoons please
so that is
pomegranate molasses so it's like an
aged balsamic vinegar but really reduced
down give that a nice mix up
is it going to be very sweet dad a
little taste
it's sweet but sour
yeah it is
it's so good though no
take
a nice spoon
put it inside the quail you can even do
this
the night before because if you pop them
in the fridge let the quail marinate
anywhere from half an hour to overnight
for my ultimate middle eastern dessert
it's got to be baklava
start by melting butter in a pan
chop pistachios in a blender
[Music]
then combine with caster sugar and lemon
zest
[Music]
brush the melted butter around a small
baking tray
place half a sheet of filler pastry on
the base
brush well with melted butter
and sprinkle with a pistachio mix
repeat and press down between layers
you're looking to create 30 to 35 layers
[Music]
then cut the baklava into bite-size
rectangles and bake in a preheated oven
for 30 to 40 minutes
meanwhile make your delicious citrusy
syrup simply add water to a pan along
with caster sugar
and the zest and juice of a lemon
simmer for seven to ten minutes making
sure the sugar has fully dissolved
now to give the cloud a wonderful
sweetness remove from the oven and
whilst hot pour over the syrup so each
layer is gloriously sticky
leave the balcava to absorb the syrup
for at least 12 hours these delicious
sticky treats will keep for a week but
they're so moorish they'll be gone in a
flash
the quails have marinated now they're
ready to cook
nice hot pan
pick up your quail
and skin side down first okay
get all that nice color and always open
them up as well in the pan
okay we'll get that skin crisp crispy
that's right
smell that pomegranate i can really
smell it smells so good get all that
marinade in there
you know cook with it as well don't
waste it
how long on average does it take to cook
could you say literally
12-15 minutes in the oven
a little touch of water
in
[Music]
bring that up to the ball
into the oven 180
so 12 to 15 minutes
[Applause]
okay
the final job before serving a herby
butter bean salad to go with my quail in
pomegranate molasses
now
one of the things that i
love about middle eastern salads is the
sort of crunch
and the color as well butter beans
it's gonna be the base
of our salad
from their
little radishes
and sort of top
and tail them get them like that
and throw them in
there's nothing small and dainty in
there okay so
with the spring
onions nice we're gonna use the greens
and the whites i'm gonna slice
along that way this time it's got those
nice light shards okay yeah
now
the croutons
are made out of these little pita breads
just slice lengthways in with a salad oh
yes
so this salad is all about texture so
cucumber okay
and take out your seeds
how come you're taking the seeds out it
just makes the salad
very watery
it's like a shower okay
cucumber juice delicious i think there
should go yeah you got me going you
really got me going no no no oh yeah
i've got revision to be doing don't
worry this is far more important trust
me who needs exams where you can cook
for a living
you gave me with my exams it's fine it's
fine it's fine be a chef for a living
have a proper job don't take your things
out like that you'll be thumbless let's
go
now
your cucumber in
from there
take your nice
vibrant tomatoes slice down
it almost looks like a greek salad as
well colors it resembles that that's
right and with the celery
like before yeah lengthwise so we need
some mint and parsley
i want you sprinkling it in there
really mix it through the herbs give it
that nice kind of freshness
but i want a bit of a bite in there now
i love pomegranate so
just carefully
open that up
okay and then just dot them on top so we
got a bit of fruitiness now into the
salad
for crunch simply cut up whole pita
breads fry in a really hot pan with
olive oil until wonderfully golden
crispy and irresistible
out
into a
sieve
okay
next a sprinkle of sumac
that's a dried fruit from middle east
the zest of a lemon
and the juice
then a drizzle of olive oil
and last but not least my crunchy pitter
croutons
croutons on oh they've gotten hard oh
just lift that up
and mix in with your hands there nice
and juicy just with fingertips there you
go so you just mix there you go it
doesn't crush anything it doesn't crush
anything but then let's just take
a little bean
wow
is that delicious um
nice
now quail
it's got that really
mmm sort of toasted almost like a sort
of light smells so good barbecue flavor
can't wait to try it
beef wow
just finely a bit of lemon zest it just
lightens everything up a little bit
and it goes so well with the pomegranate
now just
wow
that'll smell better than any boyfriend
you'll ever have oh my god
i beg to differ
okay good let's go
how delicious is that so delicious
my middle eastern feast of quail with a
pomegranate molasses and butter bean
salad with batlava to follow when dishes
are this aromatic and colorful there's
no wonder that middle eastern food
is always a hit
i know you love chocolate right
we'll break this up so it melts nice and
evenly
all right that goes over a memory and
you can't put the chocolate in direct
contact with the gas yeah okay otherwise
it will split crack four eggs in that
room please of course hold on like that
on the side and then your fingers in
and pull out okay
good
nice
now you're cracking eggs with one hand
nice one i need some mussels okay start
whisking and i'll fold in a bit of sugar
come on let's do 30 seconds each ready
okay
come on jack give it some 13 year old
welly come on some muscles
10 seconds to go nine eight
seven six
five
four
three
two one all right here we go your tummy
sugar let's go
you see the secret to whisking
vigorously is changing hands every 10
seconds yep now i'm going to stir the
chocolate i'll stir that up
now the secret behind this is getting it
really nice and thick and that's like a
stabbing on okay your turn come on
change change again yeah of course also
the chocolate leave that to slightly
cool down a touch
from there
cream in
why putting the cream in separately
because i'm gonna get it nice and thick
first if you start whisking that i'm
gonna get in the vanilla
to maximize the flavor from a vanilla
bean cut the pot in half lengthways and
scrape out those wonderfully aromatic
seeds
for extra flavor put the pod in as well
but remember to take it out once it's
infused
so we've got three components the melted
chocolate yes sugar yes and the eggs
whipped up
and the cream with the vanilla next mix
in your melted chocolate with the sugar
and egg saber on so you got a nice
rich
chocolate ganache smell that delicious
now i'm putting the cream and so you
just
whisk that in
now look at that how gorgeous is that
looking
and that my son
is a chocolate semi-freddo
now they taste
[Music]
pistachio that's right sprinkle them in
now get your baking tray you line that
with cling film so it's easy to pull out
once it sets and then you just pour that
in
that is a real treat
so you fold that over okay is this like
ice cream in any way yeah as it sets
you slice it it's like this nice
chocolate ice block delicious
then put your semifredo into the freezer
for around three hours to set
right jack get that pan nice and hot
recognize that fillet of beef this is a
rolls-royce cup of beef so we've got to
treat it with some respect okay yeah mop
up all that seasoning
yeah
into the pan and get that really nice
and hot hello guys
um
what's that
what's the name
bit of garlic and thyme in there
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef
there's hardly any fat on there so you
sear it quickly
ends as well gets seared
gonna now put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs
now
baste that with the butter
see
dad are we just having this or we're
gonna have something with it now we're
gonna serve some beautiful baked
potatoes with truffle and a salsa verde
into the oven eight to ten minutes
that's all
next my super special baked new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper
place into an oven preheated at 180
degrees celsius and bake for 35 minutes
until crisp on the outside and soft all
the way through
transfer to your serving dish and grate
over fresh parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
bake new potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
[Music]
right salsa birthday
anchovies little touch of anchovy oil in
there okay
after that we've got some capers
garlic
in with the anchovies and the capers
okay a touch
of salt one only a touch because you
call the salt in the afternoon that's
right well then diesel mustard
sherry vinegar give that a nice mix
now this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley i want half
of it in there
pureed
a touch of olive oil in there in
the rest of the mint
a touch of salt
pepper
excited
yep
you know it tastes
might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check
stop you can't kiss any boys now
before the kids polish off all the
sounds of elderly i need a distraction
and i think my b phillip will do the job
nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that seared and look how juicy
and tender that is
take that out and let that sit
on there
a little spoon just while it sits and
rests obviously
as the beef cools down that south of the
other marinades
that
goes to the table very carefully please
tails take it over the baked potatoes
please all right send me photo
now
look at that nice
[Applause]
wow and then you just get the chocolate
and you grate it
over
wow
[Music]
she's gorgeous
how delicious is that let's get one do
not drop that please okay i'm going up
to my bedroom now jack
this is my ultimate special occasion
dinner
the tenderest rare beef fillet with
punchy salsa velde
served with extravagant truffled new
potatoes
and a sublime chocolate pistachio
semifredo
[Music]